Générique
...
-Bienvenue dans
"Ces idées qui gouvernent le monde".
Créativité et folie
ou le coup de hache dans la tête.
A considérer le temps long
de la civilisation,
nous vivons
un grand moment de bouleversement
culturel, scientifique et politique.
Du culte à la culture
et au culturel,
c'est toute l'histoire de l'art,
de la crise de l'art,
que nous observons,
même si les chefs-d'oeuvre
du passé demeurent
des vigies artistiques.
Des arts aux sciences,
le 19e siècle consacre avec Darwin
l'origine animale de l'homme.
Avec Freud, c'est l'inconscient
qui éclaire sa part d'intimité
dans l'élucidation des rêves.
On pourrait évoquer
les autres transformations,
de l'économie
à la physique quantique.
Au 20e siècle et résultant
de toutes ces évolutions,
l'exploration des neurosciences
bat son plein
et imprime en quelque sorte
un rythme biologique
à la psychologie.
Alors, de tout cela
et de manière sommairement cadrée,
on pourrait toutefois
trouver un fil rouge
d'explication, d'élucidation,
un pari d'humanisme
aux évolutions passées et présentes
de notre homo sapiens
si on accepte de se mettre
à l'écoute de la parole folle
chère au philosophe Michel Foucault.
Si l'on examine
la part de folie qui se tisse
dans le caractère sacré de la vie
et dont le lien
avec la créativité semble
scientifiquement fondé.
En témoigne avec majesté
la créativité immortelle
des grands artistes,
mais pas que.
Dans la mesure où la créativité
est aussi à l'oeuvre au détour
de ce que l'on peut appeler
la vulnérabilité humaine,
quand elle s'exprime
pour se libérer
de ses entraves et de ses tourments.
Tout est comme dans la vie
en quelque sorte,
dès lors que nous vivons pour
oeuvrer, pour faire quelque chose.
Pour en parler, je vous présente
mes invités. Raphaël Gaillard,
vous êtes psychiatre,
vous êtes directeur du pôle
hospitalo-universitaire
de psychiatrie
à l'hôpital Sainte-Anne.
Camille Laura Villet,
vous êtes philosophe
et psychanalyste.
Clotilde Leguil, vous êtes
psychanalyste et philosophe.
Marc Lambron,
vous êtes écrivain
de l'Académie française.
Alors, vous venez de voir
cette citation de Diderot :
"Les grands artistes ont un petit
coup de hache dans la tête."
Alors, commençons
par cette citation qui donne
son titre, Raphaël Gaillard,
à votre dernier ouvrage.
Qu'est-ce qu'elle nous dit
et plus personnellement,
qu'est-ce qui vous a conduit
à vous pencher
sur ce coup de hache ?
-Alors, personnellement,
c'est avant tout mon étonnement
chaque matin renouvelé
devant la fréquence
des troubles mentaux.
Pourquoi sont-ils si fréquents ?
Le pôle que je dirige
à Sainte-Anne reçoit
à peu près 12 000 patients par an.
Et peut-être ne le savez-vous pas,
mais la schizophrénie affecte à peu
près 1 % de la population générale,
la dépression touche
1 personne sur 5,
sur l'ensemble de sa vie.
Donc pourquoi c'est si fréquent ?
Et quand on s'interroge
sur cette fréquence,
en ayant comme canevas
dans notre réflexion biologique
le darwinisme que vous avez évoqué,
on se dit qu'il y a quelque chose
qui porte les troubles mentaux,
qui porte la folie,
qui en ferait peut-être un avantage,
et rapidement,
ce qu'il se dit, ce qui se pense,
c'est l'idée
que folie et créativité sont liées.
-Et alors,
le coup de hache ?
-Evidemment,
Diderot l'exprime à sa façon avec
ce petit coup de hache dans la tête.
J'ai toujours été gêné
par cette hypothèse
d'un lien entre folie et créativité.
A la fois, au quotidien
de mon exercice, je vois bien
les liens entre folie et créativité
et en même temps, je vois surtout
des personnes en grande souffrance
et ma vocation de médecin est
de les soulager,
plutôt qu'être fasciné
par une hypothétique créativité.
Donc j'ai voulu renouveler
cette question, en tout cas
m'y confronter concrètement,
et j'ai été étonné de découvrir
que les sciences,
différentes sciences,
l'épidémiologie, la génétique,
les neurosciences, amènent
à renouveler la question, notamment
en faisant un pas de côté,
c'est toujours utile en matière
de psy de faire un pas de côté,
en constatant que ce lien,
il existe, il est avéré,
mais ça n'est pas
un lien de superposition,
c'est un lien de parenté.
-On va en reparler en détail.
Cette créativité
liée à l'esprit qui déraille,
en quoi elle est présente
dans votre propre vocation ?
Marc Lambron,
vous êtes écrivain, romancier,
d'où ça vient
pour vous ?
-Vous me demandez d'emblée
si je ne suis pas un peu dérangé.
-D'une certaine manière.
-Je voudrais saluer
le livre de Raphaël Gaillard
qui est remarquable,
que d'ailleurs l'Académie française
a couronné en décembre dernier.
Dire aussi
que Raphaël Gaillard anime
une association
qui chaque année en janvier réunit
300 ou 350 psychiatres.
-Plus que ça, même.
-Ou 400.
Et chaque année, en hommage
à Jean Delay, qui était psychiatre,
académicien et père de Florence
Delay, un académicien est entendu,
ce qui m'est arrivé début 2020
et j'en suis ressorti libre.
Il est assez rare
d'être entendu par 400 psychiatres
à la fois. Bon.
-C'est ce que disait Thomas Bernhard
que la folie rendait
quelque part plus libre.
-Eh bien, c'est le cas.
Alors, après,
auto-analyse, je voudrais
quand même avoir la modestie
de parler des autres pour commencer.
Ce qui intéresse un auteur,
qui est d'abord un lecteur,
c'est précisément... Moi,
ce qui m'intrigue, ce sont,
alors, partons du 19e siècle,
des écrivains ou des philosophes
qui, au cours de leur vie
et dans le début de leur vie,
ne sont pas en quelque sorte
signalés comme étant sujets
à des troubles mentaux
et puis, ça survient.
Je pense dans le domaine allemand
ou germanique à Holderlin,
qui va passer
les 30 dernières années de sa vie
dans une sorte d'hébétude,
hébergé par un menuisier,
près du Neckar, et qui est
un des plus grands poètes,
ou à Nietzsche,
l'incident ou l'accident de Turin.
Voyant un cheval rudoyer
dans la rue, il verse
dans un état qui, semble-t-il,
va devenir irréversible.
C'est assez intéressant.
Et puis alors, il y a,
puisque nous sommes en France,
la question aussi
de la naissance de la clinique,
ou comment,
au 19e siècle essentiellement,
des états pathologiques rencontrent
des praticiens. Il y a
deux exemples éminents, c'est Nerval
et c'est Maupassant qui, les deux,
vont être traités d'ailleurs
par le même Docteur Blanche,
le célèbre Docteur Blanche.
Mais il semble
que, dans le cas de Maupassant,
il y avait des raisons organiques,
une syphilis
qui déclenche
précisément cette pathologie.
Dans le cas de Nerval, c'est plus...
C'est moins sûr.
Ca finit par un suicide.
-On va rentrer
dans le détail. Clotilde Leguil,
vous êtes psychanalyste.
Comment se manifeste ce coup
de hache ? Vous le constatez
dans votre exercice ?
Et même dans votre vocation ?
-Je trouve que ce lien effectivement
entre folie et créativité
et la façon dont Raphaël Gaillard
propose de le réinterroger
est tout à fait
précieux, parce que
c'est vrai qu'on pourrait dire
que, d'un côté,
il faut bien un grain de folie,
il faut une certaine excentricité,
il faut consentir
à une forme de déraillement
pour créer quelque chose,
mais en même temps,
quand on est psychiatre
ou quand on est psychanalyste
et qu'on est confronté
à la psychose, quand on est
confronté à des patients
qui sont hospitalisés,
qui sont dans des états de grande
vulnérabilité psychique,
on sait bien
qu'on ne peut pas
effectivement juxtaposer
la créativité et la folie.
Il faut savoir de quelle folie
on parle. Néanmoins,
je trouve intéressant aussi
de penser la créativité
comme ce qui peut,
chez certains sujets, fragiles,
faire rempart à une certaine folie,
même si c'est provisoirement,
qui peut en quelque sorte
faire tenir quelque chose.
On peut penser à Camille Claudel,
qui a pu quand même créer,
a pu quand même se sortir
d'un certain ravage
de sa relation folle
avec Auguste Rodin.
Mais finalement,
la folie a été plus forte
et son sentiment de persécution
l'a emportée.
Mais on voit quand même
que la puissance de ses sculptures,
la puissance de son style,
a à voir aussi
avec quelque chose de sa folie.
-Alors, Camille Laura Villet,
vous vous êtes penchée
sur cette question à travers les
arts. J'aimerais avoir votre avis.
-Euh... Déjà,
là, spontanément,
je pense aux artistes
qui m'ont confié,
sans le théâtre, sans la peinture,
j'aurais versé dans la folie.
Et c'est quelque chose
qui m'a toujours touchée,
mais au-delà de touchée,
bouleversée, et sans doute conduite
à cette interrogation :
qu'est-ce qui distingue
une oeuvre qui sauve,
une oeuvre que j'appellerais
une oeuvre symbole,
d'une oeuvre symptôme ?
Et je crois que cette différence
entre ce qui est de l'ordre
du symbole et de l'ordre du symptôme
m'a vraiment intéressée
et a été le point de départ
de mon questionnement sur le sujet.
Qu'est-ce que le sujet humain ?
L'artiste est marqué,
vous en parlez très bien dans
votre ouvrage, Raphaël Gaillard,
par cette schize
qui caractérise le sujet humain,
par le fait
d'être séparé de la réalité,
et de ne pas
l'avoir parfaitement recouvert
et refoulé, cette séparation,
et de devoir sans cesse
jeter un pont.
Et c'est le fait de jeter un pont,
l'acte créatif
comme le fait de jeter un pont.
-Permettez-moi de profiter
de votre science de l'Antiquité
pour voir si vous retrouvez ça
dans l'Antiquité.
-C'est vrai que je suis
une passionnée de mythologie.
Il y a deux choses,
d'abord, le coup de hache,
dans la tête, forcément,
vous en parlez
à la fin de votre livre,
c'est le coup de hache que subit
le malheureux Zeus pour donner
naissance à sa fille, Athéna.
Et cette naissance a quelque chose
d'éminemment prometteur et créatif,
puisqu'on voit naître une femme
qui détient un principe masculin.
Et elle naît d'un homme
qui a intégré, avalé carrément,
un principe féminin,
Mètis, la ruse.
Et donc vont se trouver
mis l'un en face de l'autre
masculin et féminin,
en miroir l'un de l'autre,
contenant l'autre de soi.
Et une promesse
de dialectique, d'échange,
de réciprocité me semble être posée
à l'occasion de cette naissance.
Et le 2e point,
une fois que j'ai dit ça,
il y en a quand même un,
il y en a plusieurs,
mais il y en a un
dans la mythologie, on ne cesse
et pendant
toute une partie de la tragédie,
on ne cesse
de se demander s'il est fou,
victime
d'un syndrome de persécution
ou bien si véritablement
les Erinyes lui courent après,
c'est Oreste.
Et la résolution de la tragédie
passe par Athéna,
qui va inventer
le premier tribunal public.
Et donc,
là, il y a véritablement création,
création d'un nouvel ordre politique
et je ne m'étendrai pas davantage.
-Ca vous interpelle,
Marc Lambron,
ces mythologies ?
-Ce qui m'intéresse
dans les premiers échanges,
c'est est-ce que, question,
est-ce que
l'extraversion du symptôme
à travers une oeuvre d'art
peut être salvatrice ?
Parce que là,
on parle d'une oeuvre d'art
comme quelque chose
qui serait presque curatif,
en tout cas comme un exutoire
ou une libération d'un trouble
ou d'un tourment intérieur.
Et ça, c'est les praticiens
ou les philosophes qui peut-être
peuvent nous dire si l'art soigne
ou, au contraire,
si c'est une sorte de pis-aller
et de spirale, voilà,
sans issue ou sans recours.
-Alors, l'art soigne,
Raphaël Gaillard ?
-Oui, l'art soigne
et il y a beaucoup à dire
de la façon
dont ce pont jeté,
dont cet exercice,
ce tissage dans l'oeuvre d'art
peut permettre de consolider,
conduire et stabiliser
ou même permettre d'accomplir
chez une personne fragile,
mais, dans le même temps,
j'ai une petite réticence,
parce que, au motif
de cette vertu potentielle de l'art,
il est volontiers dit
qu'il faudrait ne pas soigner.
Et vous voyez, je reviens
à ma contradiction interne initiale.
Il est volontiers dit
que le chemin de résolution
d'un trouble mental
ou d'une fragilité
serait l'art et pas le soin
et ce discours-là
que tout psychiatre
a entendu chez ses patients,
l'entourage de ses patients,
éloigne ces mêmes patients
des soins et donc
les fait davantage souffrir.
Donc j'y souscris
en même temps que je m'en méfie.
-Moi, ce que je voudrais, c'est
que, on va parler
un peu des traumatismes, etc.,
mais je voudrais d'abord évoquer
la question de la jouissance.
Est-ce qu'il faut un petit coup
de hache pour être créatif ?
Et je voudrais vous soumettre
cette réflexion
de Tchekhov :
"J'imagine que pour celui
qui a goûté aux délices
"de la création artistique, il
n'existe pas d'autre jouissance."
Qu'en pensez-vous, Clotilde Leguil ?
-J'aime beaucoup Tchekhov.
Evidemment, c'est une phrase qui
nous touche, on a envie d'y croire,
que la création artistique
procure une jouissance
qui est aussi intensification
de la vie, de la pulsion de vie.
Mais c'est vrai que, disons,
au cas par cas, dans la clinique,
les choses sont aussi peut-être
plus complexes.
Par exemple, je pense,
puisqu'on se demandait
si cette jouissance de la création,
elle soigne. Est-ce qu'elle est
curatrice ? Par exemple,
si on pense à Marguerite Duras,
quand elle a écrit "Lol V. Stein",
elle écrit sur un personnage
qui est en proie
à une forme de folie.
D'ailleurs, elle s'est inspirée
pour ce personnage d'une patiente
qu'elle a vue dans un hôpital
psychiatrique lors d'un bal.
Et,
alors, est-ce que
l'écriture de "Lol V. Stein"
l'aide elle finalement
à faire tenir quelque chose
de son propre être et de son corps
ou est-ce que finalement
ça ne la fragilise pas
davantage ? A la fois,
elle a écrit un texte inouï,
qui nous traverse chacun
quand on le lit,
qui nous fait éprouver une forme de
ravissement et elle témoigne après,
je trouve ça très intéressant
dans ses écrits, dans son journal,
qu'elle a eu du mal
à en revenir de ce texte,
qu'elle reste habitée par Lol et
qu'après avoir écrit "Lol V. Stein",
elle s'est mis à parler d'elle-même
à la 3e personne,
c'est-à-dire qu'elle ne retrouvait
plus en quelque sorte son "je".
C'est intéressant,
parce que, à partir
du témoignage singulier,
là, de Duras,
on aperçoit
que, effectivement, il y a une
jouissance inouïe dans la création,
qui peut aller jusqu'à se perdre
soi-même, se laisser
traverser par quelque chose,
et en même temps, il y aussi
un risque pris par le sujet.
-Vous constatez cette jouissance,
Raphaël Gaillard ?
-Oui...
-D'ailleurs,
avez-vous pris... j'allais dire,
est-ce que ça a procuré
une jouissance d'avoir
écrit "Le coup de hache" ?
Pardonnez cette...
-Question
indiscrète.
-...interpellation indiscrète.
-La jouissance du style,
elle se sent. Ecrire.
-Merci.
J'ai pris beaucoup de plaisir
à écrire, parce que mon écriture
est une écriture habituellement
de scientifique,
qui est une écriture très pauvre,
puisqu'elle a vocation uniquement
à transcrire des idées très simples
et poser des hypothèses
auxquelles on répond
de la façon la plus simple
et directe possible,
évidemment en anglais.
Donc j'ai pris du plaisir
à l'écriture
et à une sorte de vagabondage
qui n'est pas
mon écriture scientifique.
Sur la question de la jouissance,
là aussi, nous pourrions répondre
à un grand Russe par un grand Russe.
Quand on lit, par exemple,
les descriptions
que Dostoïevski faisait de l'aura
de l'épilepsie,
l'aura de l'épilepsie,
ces premiers temps qui précèdent
la crise d'épilepsie,
qu'il décrit comme étant
d'une félicité incroyable,
quelque chose que personne d'autre
ne peut connaître, où on peut parler
probablement de jouissance,
mais de jouissance qui consiste là
à embrasser l'univers entier
dans cette excitation initiale
de tous les neurones,
qui fait les prémices
de la crise d'épilepsie.
Eh bien,
voilà un grand auteur qui décrit
un mouvement pathologique,
l'épilepsie,
qu'on ne lui souhaite pas,
comme étant source
d'une félicité infinie
et je me demande ce faisant
si on se trompe pas d'objectif
en pensant en termes de jouissance,
parce que je ne suis pas sûr
que ce soit là
que l'oeuvre se fasse,
il faut qu'elle se tienne, l'oeuvre,
beaucoup plus qu'elle soit
la marque d'une jouissance.
-Je voudrais vous interroger
sur un cas clinique.
-Oui.
-J'ai rencontré
une grande dame de la peinture
qui habitait
dans un faubourg de Jérusalem.
Elle avait une maladie de Parkinson
très accusée et très tôt.
Mais quand elle peignait,
ça disparaissait
complètement. Qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez en déduire ?
-Je vais pas en déduire
grand-chose sans connaître
la grande dame en question.
-C'est une impression,
parce qu'on dit que...
-Deux choses.
D'abord, dans la clinique
de la maladie de Parkinson,
le tremblement est un tremblement
qui classiquement
s'arrête à l'action,
c'est-à-dire que
c'est quelque chose qui entrave
sauf au moment de l'action.
Et par exemple, nous avons vu
des chirurgiens continuer à opérer
et bien opérer étant pourtant
atteints de maladie de Parkinson.
Dans l'action même,
quelque chose se remet
en place. Ensuite, il y a
une sorte de mémoire du corps,
de quelque chose
qui traverse l'individu,
qui à ce moment-là
le met en mouvement, en passant
outre le handicap,
qui est un handicap très moteur
dans la maladie de Parkinson.
Et donc c'est pas très étonnant
d'avoir ces moments
paradoxaux
de grande fluidité motrice
chez une personne
par ailleurs très handicapée.
-Que pensez-vous
de cette sublimation par les arts ?
Qui veut dire un mot là-dessus ?
Marc Lambron ?
-Je sais pas si c'est seulement
de la sublimation.
Prenons le cas des auteurs,
des écrivains. Il y a
plusieurs situations, plusieurs
postures par rapport à la folie.
Il me semble que,
ce qu'on appelle la folie,
nous commencions à parler de ceux,
souvent des grands artistes
ou des grands auteurs,
qui ont été comme...
qui écrivent depuis la fournaise
d'un état intérieur.
Ca peut être Nietzsche.
Ca peut être le haut mal
comme on disait au 19e siècle,
l'épilepsie, et le cas d'Artaud
est évidemment pris en compte
par la clinique et on peut parler
de ce qu'était
la clinique à ce moment-là
et de ce qu'il écrit
quand il en sort.
C'est la première chose
et, à mon avis, ça s'accompagne
de souffrances intérieures.
La question de la jouissance,
à mon avis, n'est pas là.
Il y a
une deuxième famille d'écrivains
et vous les évoquez
dans votre livre,
ce sont ceux qui, mettons,
sains d'esprit, entre guillemets,
s'essaient à ce qu'on peut appeler
des psychoses expérimentales,
c'est-à-dire les stupéfiants,
les drogues.
Et il y a des écrivains
éminents qui n'ont jamais
été regardés comme fous,
au sens clinique,
par exemple, Huxley,
"Les portes de la perception",
qui sont Michaux, dont vous parlez,
les écrits mescaliniens de Michaux,
et même Junger,
le prussien Junger,
qui écrit dans les années 70
un livre qui s'appelle
"Approches, drogues et ivresse"
qui sont des relevés... Ce qu'avait
fait Walter Benjamin avant lui,
sur le hashish et sur la morphine,
je crois.
Bon. Donc ces écrivains-là
qui en reviennent,
qui ne vont pas être traités,
ils vont chercher
quelque chose en tout cas,
ce sont des voleurs de feu
ou cela fait partie
de leur stratégie d'écriture
que d'aller
vers des états psychiques provoqués
sous substances.
Et puis, il y aurait
une dernière façon
de s'approcher de la folie,
qui serait peut-être la mienne
dans quelques-uns de mes livres,
c'est en toute connaissance de cause
inventer un personnage
un peu cinoque,
si vous me permettez l'expression.
Prenez Malraux,
alors, Malraux était
lui-même évidemment sujet
à toutes sortes d'états
polymorphes, mais il y a
dans son oeuvre un personnage
qui s'appelle Clappique.
Il est
dans "La condition humaine"
et on le revoit 30 ans plus tard
dans les "Antimémoires",
qui est une sorte
d'illuminé colonial
qui vit au milieu des tribus
et qui a un discours
très efflorescent,
très délirant.
Malraux adorait ce qu'il appelait
les farfelus.
Là, on voit qu'il y a un plaisir.
Pour le coup, il y a une jouissance
d'écrivain depuis un socle
de rationalité à inventer
un délirant. Il y a plusieurs
régimes d'écriture et plusieurs
approches, plusieurs possibles
dans la gamme d'un auteur.
-Clotilde Leguil, vous constatez
cette jouissance ?
-Je voudrais
poursuivre cette typologie du
rapport à l'écriture et à la folie,
il y a aussi certains écrivains,
mais c'est très rare,
qui témoignent dans leur écriture
même d'un moment de folie véritable
et non pas de psychose provoquée
par les stupéfiants,
de recherche
d'un état au fond de...
une sorte d'extase
qui leur permettrait de créer.
Je pense quand même à un témoignage
qui est rare et moi, cliniquement,
ça m'a beaucoup intéressée,
je sais pas ce que Raphaël
Gaillard va en penser, mais
le témoignage d'Emmanuel Carrère
dans son livre "Yoga".
Emmanuel Carrère
a écrit "Le royaume", on peut dire
qu'il y a un effet là
de sublimation,
où il parvient à être reconnu,
au moment où le livre sort,
comme surplombant
la rentrée littéraire.
Il y a quelque chose
du grand auteur. Il parle
de la nomination de grand auteur
qui lui fait
un certain effet de jouissance.
Et c'est assez extraordinaire
le courage qu'il a eu dans "Yoga"
de témoigner
de quelque chose finalement
qui n'a pas tenu pour lui
et de ce moment
d'effondrement mélancolique.
Il ne décrit pas toute la causalité,
puisqu'il la garde pour son histoire
intime, mais il décrit quand même
ce moment de souffrance intense,
où effectivement
il demande là à être
soigné. Il ne demande pas juste,
il ne cherche pas là
à s'en sortir par la création,
au moment où il est dans
cet effondrement. Il doit être
soigné pour pouvoir
écrire à nouveau.
-On a ça chez Virginia Woolf,
par exemple.
Et même chez Philippe Labro,
un auteur
qui a écrit assez courageusement
sur cette dépression.
Qui écrivent au coeur de
et là qui sont comme des témoins,
des téléscripteurs si j'ose dire,
des diaristes d'états
intérieurs douloureux
et souvent curables d'ailleurs.
-Merci.
Alors, Camille Laura Villet,
vous vous êtes intéressée
dans votre travail
sur les arts, notamment
sur Brancusi,
à la question de l'héritage
et de l'identité.
Alors, vous voyez
ce que dit Picasso :
"Un peintre a toujours un père
et une mère. Il ne sort pas
"du néant."
Est-ce que vous pensez que la folie
ne sort pas du néant ?
-Je pense que la folie,
je le dirais comme ça,
c'est l'épreuve du néant,
qui ne peut être surmontée.
L'homme est traversé constamment
par le néant,
c'est son défi en tant qu'homme
que de devoir le surmonter,
que de devoir, à partir
de ce néant qui le traverse,
tisser quelque chose,
faire émerger le logos, la parole,
qu'on a traduit souvent par raison,
et il n'y arrive pas forcément.
-Alors,
pour prolonger
cette question du néant,
Raphaël Gaillard,
d'après René Char, les êtres blessés
ont plus facilement accès
aux sphères supérieures,
en tout cas disons
à une intelligence
plus proche du soleil.
Comment vous expliquez
cet accès privilégié
chez les personnes qui sont
un peu fêlées si je puis dire ?
-Et la lucidité
est la blessure
la plus rapprochée du soleil.
En fait, je persévère
dans mon souhait
de faire un pas de côté,
parce que je pense, en fait,
que plutôt
qu'aller chercher forcément
chez l'artiste ce qui fait chez lui
un cas si singulier,
ce qui
pourrait être l'origine
de son oeuvre,
je pense qu'il vaut mieux qu'on
s'intéresse à ce qu'il représente
de nos facultés à nous tous,
êtres humains.
Et, évidemment, il y a
quelque chose d'exacerbé
chez l'artiste, évidemment qu'il y a
quelque chose qui est radicalisé
par rapport au commun des mortels.
Mais je pense
que c'est plus intéressant
d'aller regarder ce qui appartient
aux êtres humains et qui n'est pas
le seul fait de l'artiste.
Et donc, ce pas de côté,
il nécessite de considérer
que ce n'est pas toujours
folie-créativité,
mais qu'est-ce qui pourrait exister
qui lie folie et créativité.
Je pense
que, si on se décale
un tout petit peu,
la réflexion nous permet
de ne pas simplement considérer
tous ces artistes
qui manifestement ont
un petit coup de hache dans la tête
ou bien la question
de l'accomplissement,
comme nous y avons réfléchi, dans
une oeuvre d'art
pour une personne
ayant une vulnérabilité
pour un trouble mental.
Et ce qu'elle peut
consolider, en quoi elle est
thérapeutique. Je pense
que l'idée qu'il puisse
y avoir chez chacun
une faculté à perdre la raison,
en tout cas, dériver,
nous éloigner du réel,
et par là aussi,
créer quelque chose,
et donc, nous autres, êtres humains,
puissions à la fois
créer et nous perdre,
ça, ce serait peut-être le lien
qui nous intéresse
pour revisiter
cette question folie et créativité.
-Ca tombe très bien.
On va parler du commun des mortels.
Qui possède souvent
un grain de folie.
Bon, les troubles mentaux font
partie de la condition humaine.
Clotilde Leguil,
quand vous êtes à l'écoute
de cette parole folle, si je puis
dire, dont parle Foucault,
comment on en sort
pour ne pas s'égarer dans la folie ?
Je peux vous aider en vous disant
que Philip Roth
à propos de sa dépression,
il dit que le supplice épouvantable
s'avéra libérateur.
-Bah, c'est-à-dire que moi... Vous
avez prononcé là le terme important,
c'est le terme de parole.
Il me semble que la folie,
c'est pas...
Moi, je l'aborderais pas
nécessairement
comme un rapport au néant,
je l'aborderais plutôt depuis
la référence qui est la mienne,
celle de la psychanalyse lacanienne,
celle de ce que dit Lacan
sur la folie très tôt,
dès 1946
dans des débats avec Henri Ey
que vous citez aussi,
c'est que la folie a à voir
avec la signification.
Elle a à avoir avec
un certain rapport au sens.
Elle a à voir avec une souffrance
qui est liée au sens
que l'on peut donner
à ce qui nous arrive,
une souffrance qui est liée au fond
à la façon dont la parole de l'autre
peut nous percuter
et ouvrir une faille
dans notre être.
La façon
dont nous pouvons nous sentir
persécuté par une parole. La folie a
donc à voir avec la dimension
de l'interprétation.
Et effectivement, il y a quelque
chose de l'ordre d'une faille
qui peut s'ouvrir
chez certains sujets
dans ce rapport à la signification
et qui peut ouvrir
sur une dimension délirante.
Alors, je distinguerais la faille
qui existe en chacun
dans le rapport à la parole
et à ce qui peut
nous faire souffrir,
de ce qui nous revient
des paroles des autres,
et puis cette faille
qui peut confronter un sujet
à une forme de trou, une forme
de disparition subjective,
et qui fait en effet
qu'il va ne plus reconnaître
ses propres productions psychiques
dans ses pensées,
dans les hallucinations
qui vont l'assaillir,
dans les automatismes mentaux
dont il va être la proie,
mais tout ça,
je le définirais... enfin,
ces manifestations de la folie,
depuis un certain rapport
à la parole et au langage.
Et au fond, rencontrer le fou, c'est
déjà rencontrer une certaine parole
et pouvoir laisser aussi le sujet
témoigner de ce qui lui arrive.
-Alors, Marc Lambron,
je voudrais pas
vous mettre dans un schéma
schizophrénique
dont a parlé Raphaël
Gaillard, mais vous êtes romancier,
est-ce que les personnages
que vous inventez,
que vous créez, viennent
interpréter, si je puis dire,
ce qu'on vient d'évoquer ?
Et est-ce que c'est plus facile
à travers des personnages
qu'à travers vous-même par exemple,
qui êtes l'écrivain,
de corriger ces failles
et de les normaliser
en quelque sorte ?
-Là, on pourrait prendre
peut-être l'artiste
comme faussaire,
c'est-à-dire il peut y avoir
des bénéfices de la folie simulée.
On parlait de Picasso.
Si vous prenez quelqu'un comme Dali,
par exemple, Salvatore Dali,
est-ce que vous allez le
caractériser
comme un personnage insensé
ou est-ce qu'il n'y a pas
une part d'histrionisme jouissive
chez lui
qui précisément campe un personnage
qui va être cet Avida Dollars
dont parlaient les surréalistes ?
Si vous prenez le rock,
par exemple,
et les groupes de hard rock,
la façon dont scéniquement,
très souvent,
il y a une sorte
de folie dionysiaque,
qui est organisée,
mais qui est parfaitement contrôlée
avec toutes les postures,
donc voilà une folie
et on dit, ce concert était fou,
etc., qui en réalité est
tout à fait incorporée
dans des circuits commerciaux.
Et même quand,
plus modestement, j'étais jeune
et qu'il y avait un service
militaire, un certain nombre
de mes contemporains simulaient,
apprenaient, prenaient des fiches
sur qu'est-ce que c'est que telle
pathologie ou tel symptôme pour être
réformé, je crois, P4.
Il y avait une nosographie.
Donc je serais intéressé
d'entendre Raphaël Gaillard
là-dessus,
sur la folie qui peut
être instrumentalisée
et qui peut être simulée et qui peut
être après tout jouissive
ou libératrice, car faire le fou-fou
comme on dit des enfants
peut aussi être agréable,
voire libérateur.
Voire rémunérateur
pour certains artistes.
-Camille Laura Villet,
continuons là-dessus,
à propos de cette folie créatrice,
la part du traumatisme.
On dit que le trauma
et la folie et la création
quelquefois en partie liés.
Dans un échange
avec le conservateur
de musée Jean Clair,
il observait qu'après la guerre,
on avait un certain retour
dans la peinture à la figuration.
Qu'est-ce que ça évoque
pour vous ?
C'est-à-dire retrouver le sens
de l'humain après le traumatisme.
On a besoin
de ça ?
-Je pense que l'homme est
profondément inachevé
et qu'un traumatisme,
comme le traumatisme
qui survient au cours d'une guerre,
peut ébranler
si fortement cette image,
la conscience d'une identité,
qu'il est nécessaire
de la réinventer.
D'où peut-être
le besoin
de reformuler
les contours d'une figure.
Et incontestablement,
les arts réfractent
les traumatismes.
Le traumatisme peut être une sorte
de catalyseur,
mais également ce qu'il va falloir
mettre à distance,
conjurer par l'exercice de l'art.
Récemment, l'exposition Kokoschka
m'a beaucoup troublée
au musée d'Art moderne.
-Très grande exposition.
-Toute la période
de la guerre, on sent
une défiguration pour le coup.
C'est pas l'après-guerre
où la figure va
pouvoir revenir,
mais il y a une défiguration
et j'ai même trouvé,
c'était très personnel,
mais comme une laideur,
mais pas une laideur
au sens d'un mauvais peintre,
une laideur au sens... comme si
la laideur du monde s'emparait
du pinceau du peintre.
Donc le traumatisme vient parler.
Peut-être que les artistes,
justement parce qu'ils ont
cette extrême sensibilité,
touchent à certains moments
ce que les philosophes appellent
l'immédiateté sensible,
la médiation est réduite
à presque zéro
et ils vont comme réfracter
ce qui se joue autour d'eux.
-Vous voulez dire
quelque chose, Raphaël ?
-Je pense que dans le traumatisme
de la guerre, il y a quelque chose,
effectivement,
qui désorganise,
qui fait perdre
la forme et les structures.
On pourrait considérer que le modèle
même de l'expérience de la guerre,
c'est la bombe à fragmentation.
On conçoit que la réponse
à cette fragmentation,
cette perte des contours,
soit une forme de figuration,
de retour à la forme,
comme vous le disiez tout à l'heure,
quelque chose de l'ordre du symbole,
quelque chose qui, suivant
l'étymologie du mot "symbole",
vient unir,
faire un chemin commun.
Comme vous le savez,
l'antonyme serait
le mot "diabolique".
Et donc, on voit bien
comment il y a un effort
de synthèse dans a possibilité
de penser quelque chose qui figure
et qui matérialise là où jusqu'ici,
c'était la fragmentation.
En tout cas, dans l'expérience
du traumatisme de guerre,
cliniquement,
là je parle en clinicien,
ce qui est toujours frappant,
c'est la reviviscence,
c'est-à-dire que les personnes
ayant connu la guerre
revivent ce qu'ils ont traversé
comme au moment présent.
Il suffit d'entendre une détonation,
une porte qui claque,
pour qu'ils soient,
à l'instant même,
comme ils étaient sous les bombes.
C'est-à-dire qu'il y a
quelque chose
qui annihile le temps,
et en même temps
que ça annihile le temps,
ça annihile l'espace.
Il y a quelque chose qui les plonge
là où ils étaient.
Et donc, le travail est un travail
de reconstitution, finalement,
d'une trame narrative.
D'ailleurs, beaucoup de nos
démarches psychothérapeutiques
fonctionnent autour
de cette perspective narrative
pour permettre une forme
de synthèse,
j'utiliserai à nouveau
le mot "symbolique",
qui leur permette
de reconstruire
quelque chose. Et quant à la mise
en scène dont Marc Lambron parlait,
je pense que là aussi,
il faut bien penser que
pour mettre en scène, projeter,
il faut avoir une intuition
de ce que vit le personnage,
donc c'est l'animer,
le romancer,
comme démiurge,
qui donne vie à ce personnage
qui lui échappe un peu,
une sorte
de Frankenstein.
Mais il y a quand même quelque chose
qu'il lui prête de lui.
En psychiatrie, nous utilisons
le terme de "sursimulation".
La sursimulation,
c'est l'idée
que ça n'est pas que simuler,
c'est avoir vécu
quelque chose
que l'on simule en plus.
Et peut-être qu'il y aurait
quelque chose de cet ordre qui,
là aussi, est un chemin
vers une existence hors de soi,
qui pose des grands cadres
dans le temps, dans l'espace,
là où les choses
ont été fragmentées,
dans l'expérience de la guerre,
par exemple.
-Clotilde Leguil,
sans faire
de la psychanalyse sauvage,
par rapport
à ce qui vient d'être dit,
cette reconstruction
après le désastre, si je puis dire,
est-ce qu'en psychanalyse,
c'est pas un peu le cheminement ?
On déconstruit,
on revisite ses traumatismes
et ensuite, il faut reconstruire.
-Il y a un cheminement de cet ordre,
et d'ailleurs, certains artistes
qui se confrontent à leurs traumas
ou aux traumatismes de guerre,
comme vous venez d'en parler,
nous apprennent quelque chose
sur ce qu'est
le chemin d'une analyse.
Le chemin d'une analyse,
il va consister à pouvoir déchiffrer
quelque chose de son trauma
jusqu'à affronter
ce qui va être de l'ordre
de l'indicible du trauma.
Il ne s'agira pas
seulement de pouvoir dire,
mais de pouvoir repousser
les frontières de l'indicible
pour pouvoir déchiffrer
des traces
qui ont à voir avec ce qui
s'est écrit dans le corps-même
du sujet.
Et je pense...
En vous écoutant sur la guerre,
je pense au parcours
de l'artiste allemand Richter,
sur lequel il y a eu
un très beau film, qui s'intitule
"L'oeuvre sans auteur",
qui est un peu passé inaperçu
en France,
et justement, qui témoigne
de cette rencontre à la fois
avec la folie dans la famille,
pas sa propre folie à lui
mais la folie
de sa tante et la question
du trauma infantile.
Très rapidement,
c'est un garçon qui découvre l'art
sous le nazisme
grâce à sa tante
qui l'emmène à l'âge de 6 ans
voir une exposition
qualifiée d'art dégénéré,
et sa tante, en fait,
va faire une bouffée délirante aiguë
suite au fait d'avoir été choisie
pour remettre un bouquet
au Fuhrer, et sous ses yeux,
il voit sa tante arrêtée et emmenée
par les services psychiatriques,
qui sont aussi entre les mains
de la politique nazie.
Et en fait,
tout le parcours de Richter
va consister à essayer de trouver
comment peindre,
comment trouver son style,
comment dire quelque chose
de cet événement
où il a 6 ans
et il voit sa tante
qui lui est arrachée,
qui lui a fait découvrir l'art,
et en même temps,
avec qui il ne peut plus parler.
Je trouve que c'est
un très beau film
sur ce qu'est la création,
justement,
puisqu'elle est rencontre
avec la folie de l'autre
et en même temps,
il va chercher
dans la figuration,
dans un moment où,
à l'école d'art de Dusseldorf,
la figuration n'est plus tellement
à la mode, et il cherche
dans la figuration
une solution
pour dire quelque chose
de ce trauma
qui l'a laissé sans voix.
-Marc Lambron.
-C'est pareil avec Stockhausen,
dont la mère
lui est arrachée dans les années 30,
internée psychiatrique,
et il ne la reverra jamais.
Je crois qu'elle meurt en 1941
en détention.
Ca donne Richter,
ça donne Stockhausen.
Après, l'art et la folie,
si on veut,
il y a quand même,
au 20e siècle en tout cas,
des mises en cause d'un certain
usage de la psychiatrie,
et ça n'est pas mince.
La psychiatrie eugéniste
du régime nazi,
la psychiatrie carcérale
du régime soviétique,
ça donne notamment
Soljenitsyne.
Il y a d'ailleurs des films
où le psychiatre,
où l'asile apparaît
comme un lieu
méphistophélique,
"Shock Corridor"
ou "Vol au-dessus
d'un nid de coucou",
qui sont des journalistes infiltrés
qui veulent enquêter
et qui finalement
vont rester prisonniers,
ils vont passer de l'autre côté.
Il y a eu, même, des correctifs
internes, c'est-à-dire...
Je me souviens très bien
dans les années 70
de ce qu'on a appelé
l'antipsychiatrie,
Basaglia en Italie,
Laing, Cooper, etc.,
qui était comme une façon, et même
Guattari et Deleuze en France,
donc il y a aussi cela
comme enjeu
dans l'histoire du "fou"
et du regard qu'on porte
sur la folie
et sur la façon de la traiter.
-Marc Lambron,
juste un mot.
Quand vous écrivez,
il y a des moments de blocage
qui arrivent.
Comment vous les surmontez ?
-Des moments de blocage ?
-Oui.
Quand la plume s'arrête.
-Par exemple, en dormant.
-Vous attendez que les rêves
viennent vous...
-Nous avons peu parlé des rêves.
C'est très intéressant.
Ce sont évidemment
des images déraisonnables
qui sont produites
par des personnages,
nous tous, qu'on peut regarder
comme normaux.
C'est assez intéressant,
cette efflorescence folle
de l'esprit
qui pour autant ne porte pas
conséquence quand on se réveille.
Et ça, depuis l'Antiquité.
Il y a des textes
qui témoignent de cela.
Et Freud, évidemment,
va sur la science des rêves,
c'est une des portes d'entrée
dans la naissance
de la psychanalyse.
-Freud compare davantage l'artiste
au rêveur qu'au fou.
Il dit que la création est
comme un rêve,
sauf qu'elle va pouvoir rejoindre
le monde de l'autre
et toucher la civilisation.
-Donc quand je suis en panne,
je rêve.
-Raphaël Gaillard,
on va terminer là-dessus,
sur une question
que vous évoquez dans votre livre
et que beaucoup de gens se posent.
Cette folie
créatrice,
est-ce qu'elle se transmet
de génération en génération,
et selon quel mode
de transmission ?
Parce que vous savez,
il y a beaucoup de débats,
des gens qui pensent
qu'il y a des gènes de l'autisme,
de la schizophrénie,
qui pensent qu'il y a
des gènes pour tout.
Mais vous, à votre avis,
comment tout ça
se transmet ?
-En tout cas, ce qu'on peut dire
dans les termes de la science,
premièrement,
c'est qu'évidemment,
il n'y a pas de gène
de la schizophrénie
comme il existe un gène
de la mucoviscidose,
et donc de transmission génétique
comme il existe une transmission
de la mucoviscidose.
Pour autant,
il y a des gènes
de vulnérabilité
aux troubles mentaux.
C'est justement intéressant
de constater que, par exemple,
la probabilité d'exercer
un métier créatif,
ce qui est une mesure
assez grossière de la créativité,
mais elle vaut ce qu'elle vaut,
cette probabilité est plus élevée
chez les parents,
frères et soeurs et enfants
d'une personne souffrant
d'un trouble mental
que chez cette personne elle-même.
Donc on fait ce pas de côté
et on constate que ce lien
est un lien de parenté...
-Mais pas forcément
à la génération qui suit.
-Pas forcément,
et peut-être même
davantage à la génération
d'au-dessus.
-Sans toucher la fratrie.
-Bien sûr. On l'a évoqué
pour Richter ou Stockhausen,
mais la littérature et l'histoire
des hommes et des femmes
fourmillent de ces représentations.
Il y aurait quelque chose,
comme un air de famille.
Et encore une fois,
c'est plus intéressant
de penser en termes
d'air de famille
autour de la créativité
plutôt que,
de façon forcenée,
aller chercher quelque chose
qui superpose folie et créativité,
qui vient exiger des patients
souffrant de troubles mentaux
qu'ils deviennent créatifs,
c'est une sorte de double peine,
il faudrait,
en plus d'un trouble mental,
se révéler créatif
ou affubler tout artiste
d'une étiquette
en disant : "C'est un artiste,
il a tel diagnostic",
alors que Marc Lambron
nous a expliqué
devant 400 psychiatres,
au Congrès de l'Encéphale...
-400, attention.
-4000.
-Ah bon, 4000 ?
-Vous avez été trop modeste.
Vous êtes sorti libre
et même très applaudi.
-Sur ce point,
il y avait quand même
une démonisation avec le discours
sur la tare, les tarés.
On voit ça chez Zola,
par exemple,
sur les lignages, les filiales
et la malédiction,
le fatum qui devient organique,
en passant par le fait
qu'on soit taré
et que l'alcool, etc.,
ça se transmet.
Mais tout ça est démenti.
-Je voudrais terminer
cette émission...
Je ne voudrais pas sexuer le débat
ou le genrer,
mais je vais vous poser une question
à vous, Clotilde Leguil
et à vous,
Camille Laura Villet,
pour terminer cette émission.
Est-ce qu'il faut accepter
de se perdre
pour faire oeuvre,
notamment dans la relation
amoureuse ?
-Moi, j'ai beaucoup travaillé
sur ce que Lacan appelle
"la folie féminine",
donc j'aime beaucoup cette idée
que finalement, dans l'amour,
effectivement, on peut consentir
à une forme de perte,
et que c'est même la définition
du consentement,
ce dessaisissement.
Néanmoins,
il y a aussi une dimension
de ravage dans l'amour
qu'il ne faut pas méconnaître
et qui a été aussi au coeur
de ce qui a intéressé Lacan,
c'est-à-dire la façon dont aussi
l'amour peut rendre
une femme folle.
-Et vous,
Camille Laura Villet ?
-Moi, je dirais...
Se perdre, peut-être pas,
mais s'abandonner, sûrement,
au sens de laisser la conscience
qu'on a de soi
pour aller rejoindre son autre.
Et je pense que l'homme
qu'on choisit d'aimer...
Mais pour les hommes,
c'est pareil,
c'est un point où on se rejoint.
Mais l'homme qu'on choisit d'aimer,
il n'y a pas de hasard,
il est là pour nous révéler
quelque chose,
et si on ne s'abandonne pas à lui...
-Je ne vais pas...
Je ne vais pas empêcher
les hommes d'intervenir.
Vous croyez
qu'il faut se perdre
pour être amoureux,
Raphaël Gaillard ?
Un peu ?
-Un peu, beaucoup, passionnément,
à la folie, voulez-vous dire.
-Oui.
-Un peu, beaucoup,
passionnément, à la folie.
-Marc Lambron ?
-Vous évoquiez "Le ravissement"
de Lol V. Stein,
qui est un livre d'amour.
Et dans "ravissement",
il y a le sens d'être ravi
dans le sens de la jubilation
et le fait d'être enlevé, aussi,
d'être emporté.
On pourrait faire
du néologisme lacanien
en disant
"ravissement, ravagement",
puisque vous alliez aussi
du côté du ravage.
Ca commence par "rav",
comme une rave party...
Rires
..amoureuse.
Un "rêve party" !
-On finit...
-L'amour fou, hein.
-Le parti du rêve,
il y en a un à fonder.
-Voilà.
Ecoutez, je vous remercie.
Je vais vous suggérer
une bibliographie.
Je commencerai évidemment
par Raphaël Gaillard,
vous avez publié ce fameux
"Coup de hache
"dans la tête".
Juste une impression :
depuis que le livre
a été publié,
il y a une année, je crois,
est-ce que quelque chose
a évolué chez vous
par rapport à cette publication ?
Est-ce que vous...
Des commentaires
que vous avez reçus,
des éloges, des critiques, etc. ?
Y a quelque chose...
-Personnellement,
mais c'est pas le plus important,
c'est la chance de rencontres
telles que celles-ci,
mais je pense que,
au-delà de ma propre personne,
qui n'est pas très importante,
c'est aussi la possibilité
de changer le regard sur ceux
qui souffrent de troubles mentaux,
et puisque ce lien entre folie
et créativité est avéré
mais est avéré différemment,
comme un lien de famille,
comme un lien de parenté,
je crois que ça nous amène
à placer ces personnes
au centre de la société
et pas dans une position
excentrique, marginale,
comme on l'a trop fait.
-Merci. Oui ?
-Si je lacanise...
-Ne lacanisez pas,
ça sera trop long !
-La hache, c'est le billot,
mais c'est aussi le bio.
Et Raphaël est aussi un pionnier,
on peut dire,
de la "biopsychiatrie",
on peut appeler ça comme ça.
-Marc Lambron,
vous avez publié
"Le monde d'avant".
Bientôt, ce sera
"Le monde de demain",
puisque vous aimez
publier...
-Un journal.
-Le journal, c'est juste avant.
-Et après ?
-Et après ? Je n'en sais rien,
je suis de...
Vous parliez du commun des mortels,
comme disait Cocteau.
Moi, j'appartiens
au commun des immortels.
Ma destinée va être commune,
je vais me transformer en fauteuil
après ma mort.
-Je voudrais rappeler,
quand même,
"La crise de la culture"
d'Hannah Arendt,
qui est un classique,
je voudrais rappeler
"Terre natale" de Jean Clair,
qui raconte un peu
son itinéraire.
-Son enfance dans la Nièvre.
-Son enfance,
ses rapports,
c'est chez Gallimard.
Je voudrais rappeler Clotilde
Leguil, ça date de deux ans,
"Céder n'est pas consentir",
aux PUF.
Vous êtes toujours
sur cette position-là ?
Parce que j'ai senti que vous disiez
que le coup de hache pouvait...
Finalement, ça ne serait pas
aussi rationnel que ça ?
-Moi, dans mon livre, je n'aborde
pas du tout le consentement
comme quelque chose de rationnel
et j'affirme qu'il n'y a pas
de consentement éclairé.
Pour moi, ce livre est aussi
un éloge de l'amour.
-Très bien.
Camille Laura Villet,
vous avez publié
"Les aventuriers de l'abstraction".
En deux mots,
vous pouvez dire
pourquoi vous vous êtes intéressée
à Brancusi ?
-Je me suis intéressée à Brancusi
là, dans ce livre,
essentiellement pour le procès
qu'il intenta aux Etats-Unis,
qui me permettait de comprendre
cette bascule
qui nous permet de passer
du 19e au 20e siècle
et la récupération de l'abstraction,
du geste d'abstraction
par ce que j'ai appelé
sommairement les Etats-Unis
mais qui en fait est une projection
de l'Occident aux Etats-Unis.
Et donc, c'est ça
qui m'a intéressée
pour comprendre ce qui s'était passé
au 20e siècle à travers l'art.
-La taxe s'appliquait
aux métaux ordinaires.
-Absolument.
-Merci. Merci mesdames,
merci messieurs,
d'avoir brillamment
illustré ce thème
de créativité et folie.
Je voudrais remercier
l'équipe de LCP
d'avoir permis sa réalisation,
et je vous laisse
avec cette citation :
"A défaut d'être tous géniaux",
ce qu'on regrette néanmoins,
"nous sommes doués
d'une grande plasticité
"car nous sommes très inachevés".
Est-ce que vous savez
de qui c'est ?
-Non. Un homme ou une femme,
d'abord ?
-Un homme.
-Mort ?
-Vivant.
Psychiatre.
-Un psychiatre vivant ?
-Voilà, Raphaël Gaillard.
-Je l'avais reconnu !
-Voilà.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA